would you like to hear the name of the
new web browser in Windows 10.
okay let's the video
[Music]
over the years Internet Explorer allowed
me to stay connected with friends and
family around the world
it's the browser you use to download
other browsers or at least that's what
it used to be until Microsoft finally
decided to retire Internet Explorer in
mid-2022. don't worry though Microsoft
has a replacement for Internet Explorer
called Edge and it's able to download
Google Chrome even faster in fact it's
able to download it even faster than
Chrome would be able to download it
given that it's objectively faster
according to Microsoft Edge is 112
faster than Chrome but who knows what
cherry pick data they're using something
that is surprising though is that edge
is actually faster in real world testing
as well this is what many blogs have
been claiming for quite some time now
and through my personal testing it does
appear to be true on browser bench I was
able to get a score of 270 using Edge
while I only got a score of 251 using
Chrome this wasn't just a fluke either
test after test Edge consistently only
scored about 20 points better than
Chrome and just not just snappier than
Chrome either it's also more efficient
with 60 tabs open Chrome used up 3.7
gigabytes of memory while agile only
used up 2.9 gigabytes this will be quite
noticeable for all of you who regularly
haven't dozens of tabs open I know
you're watching alright so Edge might be
marginally faster and more efficient
than other browsers but speed isn't the
only Factor when it comes to choosing a
browser there are several other factors
that you might consider such as which
one is more socially acceptable I'm just
kidding of course you don't do that but
what you might consider is the default
search engine now technically the
default search engine on edge is Bing
but Microsoft isn't hell-bent on getting
you to actually use Bing in fact you can
switch to Google within literally 10
seconds but what about the hundreds of
thousands of extensions that are
available on the Chrome web store surely
Microsoft can't compete with that right
well they don't have to because they
simply let you use the Chrome web store
the new version of edge is based on
chromium meaning that you can add any
Chrome extension to edge you can also
edit Microsoft extensions to Edge not
that Microsoft's catalog is anything to
brag about but you do have that as well
which simply gives you even more options
on top of all this Edge also has awesome
integration with Microsoft Office and
outlook for obvious reasons Edge also
comes with a lot of quirks that many
people really like such as the ability
to arrange your tabs vertically and at
the sidebar on the side of the screen so
really you get the best of both the
Google world and the Microsoft world
this is really not that surprising given
that edge is really just a faster
implementation of chrome with some
Microsoft aspects thrown in here and
there but despite this Edge is getting
destroyed in terms of market share
Chrome's market share stands at a
dominating 60 percent well I just Market
sure isn't even able to cross five
percent so why doesn't no one want Edge
it despite it being equivalent to Chrome
if not better
one of the main reasons that people
avoid Edge like the plague is because of
Internet Explorer at one point in
history internet explorer was actually
the most popular browser on the planet
but not because it was good but because
it was forced you see it before Internet
Explorer people were perfectly happy
using the World Wide Web links and of
course Netscape but in 1995 Microsoft
decided that they wanted a piece of the
internet pi as well so they came out
with Internet Explorer and knowing
Microsoft they didn't want to leave the
adoption of Internet Explorer of the
chance so they bundled Internet Explorer
in with Windows and just as they hoped
new pc users tended to use the default
browser internet explorer and this led
to the browser becoming the dominant
browser but Microsoft had gotten one
thing wrong just because Internet
Explorer was the most popular didn't not
mean that it was actually popular
amongst people at best people had a
mutual opinion on the browser while
enthusiasts hated it this wasn't to say
that internet explorer was terrible it
got the job done fine but at the same
time it wasn't anything notable either
what really triggered enthusiasts was
the fact that Microsoft forced Internet
Explorer while there were several other
great options and it wasn't just
enthusiasts that were triggered either
Regulators were also triggered Microsoft
was literally blocking computer
manufacturers from putting any other web
browser on the desktop and this was
after Microsoft agreed that they would
not bundle IE in with the windows as you
would guess Regulators did not take this
violation lightly and that this issue
would be escalated up to the Supreme
Court during the worst of it Microsoft
was actually being ordered display into
two different companies but luckily for
Microsoft this order was canceled at the
last second because the judge issuing
the order had a broken protocol by
talking to the Press so ironic quickly
it was depressed that saved Microsoft at
the Supreme Court but they by no means
helped Microsoft in the public court by
the early 2000s the general public was
well aware of how Microsoft had abused
their power with ie and they resented
Microsoft for it for many Microsoft was
the embodiment of everything that was
wrong with a capitalistic Society so
they started Living in droves and they
started supporting an open source
project Mozilla Firefox for many years
Firefox was the go-to browser not just
for enthusiasts but for Everyone by 2010
Firefox had a 33 market share while IE
had 50 market share if Firefox had a few
more years they would have overtaken Ai
and it became the most popular browser
in the world by far but Sundar piche and
the Google had a different plan they had
seen quite a bit of success within the
search and the email space and now they
wanted to challenge the likes of
Microsoft and Apple with Google Chrome
foreign
Firefox was giving Microsoft a run for
their money they had by no means lost
the game quite yet all of the F
microsofters had already left so the
people that were left were simply
looking for a functional browser and the
IE was more than capable of that so all
Microsoft had to do was keep I.E
functional but they couldn't even do
that at first glance this might be
surprising why was a multi-hundred
billion dollar company not able to keep
up with a browser a literal open source
Community was able to do that well the
answer is not a lack of resources the
answer is hubris and arrogance you see
it Microsoft had it never played by the
rules they were the ones that set the
rules and everyone else had to follow
Microsoft's rules of whether they wanted
to or not because Microsoft had the
users Microsoft approached IE with this
same attitude they didn't give a crap
about global web standards or developers
or even putting out consistent updates
Microsoft was only updating I.E once
every few years while developers were
willing to put up with this BS when IE
had 80 to 90 of market share they
stopped catering to Microsoft's needs as
Firefox and chrome started making names
for themselves unlike I.E Chrome and
Firefox were built for developers by
developers Google figured that to get
end users to switch they first needed to
get developers to switch and make
websites that ran great on their browser
fortunately for Google this wasn't that
hard to do given that Microsoft was in
hibernation the results of this weren't
immediately clear but about five years
after the launch of chrome in the early
to mid-2010s the general public started
to notice more and more websites started
to look wonky on IE people also started
to notice that their friends who used
chrome experienced less lag pure crashes
and simply had an overall smoother
experience but ie's problems stretched
much further than just being slow or
displaying websites poorly remember how
computer viruses were an actual concern
than the 20 years ago well one of the
main reasons for that is actually
Internet Explorer you see Microsoft
allowed developers to write website code
in the international standard which is
Javascript or Visual Basic script the
reasoning for this was that vbscript
could allow developers to accomplish
more advanced tasks as they would have
greater access to the user's PC but this
also meant that it was way easier to
infect computers with viruses let's just
say that this security issue was so bad
that Microsoft has since put out
tutorials on how to disable vbscript
execution So Not only was IE slower and
the wonky it was a serious security
threat I mean it's almost as if
Microsoft was actively encouraging
people to leave IE and that's exactly
what they did between 2009 and 2015 ice
market share would plummet from 65 down
to 15 clearly Microsoft's hibernation
strategy G was no longer working and
they would finally decide to do
something with the launch of Microsoft
Edge
Microsoft initially launched Edge
alongside Windows 10 and back in 2015
but while Edge had a much more modern
look than IE not much had really changed
behind the scenes Microsoft was making
all of the same mistakes that they were
making with ie for example Edge was
built on Microsoft's proprietary browser
engine Edge HTML and their chakra
JavaScript engine while these sound
fancy the reality was that edge still
didn't not support even basic open media
standards such as webm and Opus so Edge
was really just the same crappy Internet
Explorer but with a facelift we should
also mention that Microsoft was still
using their classic monopolistic
practices with Edge as it came with
Windows 10 and now Windows 11 as well
but by this point people had become a
numb into Microsoft's games downloading
a new browser using Microsoft's default
browser became a natural part of buying
a new computer nobody even bothered
checking out if Edge was actually good
or not in fact and this market share was
a laughable two percent but no worries
and it's not like any of these people
missed out on anything because energy
still sucked this didn't Remain the case
forever though as Satya Nadella the new
CEO would eventually come around to a
dressing Edge unlike his predecessors
Satya did not have the pompous Viewpoint
that Microsoft was the only and the best
choice for consumers instead it he
acknowledged their shortcomings and
embraced their competitors for example
instead of endlessly pursuing the
Windows phone he chose to embrace IOS
and Android by launching Microsoft
Office on these platforms he would carry
over the same mindset when it came to
addressing the browser space instead of
trying to outshine Chrome by developing
their own Advanced browser from scratch
he chose to embrace Chrome he
acknowledged that Chrome had won over
the users and the developers so it was
much smarter to build off of chrome
success and simply add a Windows pin to
it and that's exactly what happened at
the end of 2018 Microsoft announced that
they would be switching Edge to chromium
and at the beginning of 2020 Microsoft
would launch the new Edge
since then Edge has simply become more
and more integrated with the Chrome but
at the same time it has also become more
and more unique for example they
embraced the Chrome web store but at the
same time they also addressed Chrome's
atrocious RAM usage similarly they let
you use Google as your default search
engine but at the same time you have the
full power of a Microsoft's office suite
which let's be honest is way better than
Google's offerings Microsoft Edge is no
longer the lock into the Microsoft
ecosystem that it once used to be but
despite all this no one wants to switch
primarily because of their negative
opinion on IE and the original edge with
that being said though we can't expect
these types of switches to happen
overnight enthusiasts are starting to
notice and as Google becomes the one
that's hibernating we may just see a
non-monopolistic browser space would you
be willing to switch to Edge comment
that down below also drop a like if
you're glad that Chrome May finally see
some competition and of course consider
checking out our Discord Community to
suggest future video ideas and to
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then I'm Hari and I'll see you guys on
the next one